Games are a team effort.
You, the developer,
are often working with a designer who
decides how the game should work.
It's then your job to bring
their designs to life.
Even when you're working alone,
it's a good idea to keep these
two jobs somewhat separate.
Take your level design, for instance.
You don't want to have to write Java and
recompile your game every time you
move a platform or add a new enemy.
Ideally you'd like to use some external
purpose built level-editing tool to
create a level file,
which can then be loaded by your game.
And this level will do just that,
using the Tiled level editor to create
JSON level files, which will then turn
into an actual level object in our game.